devant le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique lance un cri d'alarmé
la centrale de zaporizhya sous contrôle
russe depuis mars doit de toute urgence
être inspectés
l'heure est grave
il agence doit être autorisée à mener sa
mission à zaporijia le plus rapidement
possible ou en avant la réunion les
nations unies avaient appelé à l'arrêt
des combats autour de l' usine ce jeudi
pourtant le site a été une nouvelle fois
touché par des tirs d'obus russie et
l'ukraine se rejettent mutuellement la
responsabilité
plusieurs capteurs de radioactivité ont
été endommagées sans que des variations
n'ait été relevé
l'ukraine comme la russie s'oppose aux
demandes des visites de lieux pour kiev
cela constituerait une reconnaissance de
l'occupation russe pour moscou la
situation sur le terrain ne permet pas
cette visite qu'elle juge inopportune
par ailleurs